hey everyone welcome to led live is
there anything
wrong with pleasure find out on this
episode of
led live
light exposing darkness all right well
welcome back
everybody to another episode today we're
going to talk about
pleasure the lust of the flesh i don't
know if you guys have ever dealt with
that before but we're going to talk
about
it we got to be real with our audience
right
it's nice to see you guys wearing
t-shirts i'm the only one
at the table who is not representing i
feel kind of out of place
but i'm representing audioverse if
you've never heard audioverse check them
out that's a free plugin for you guys so
um what do we have pray for your haters
is representing well today
yeah led live all right well we have
t-shirts we encourage you to check them
out
you can get them on teespring check out
the link below soon you will be able to
get them directly
from us which we really like um send
your pictures i'll be wearing them we'll
put them on the show too
yeah and we have stickers and we have
dvds
we got all kinds of stuff that you guys
might be interested in and they're ways
that you can help support us
also there's amazon smile if you guys
have ever heard of that just look for
little light ministries
and giving assistant we're on that as
well
also we want to encourage you to check
out our spanish
show our spanish content spanish channel
sister channel
we hope to have some steam
on that channel by the end of the year
so pray for us that we'll get more
content out on
our spanish channel all right have you
guys ever heard this before
it doesn't affect me oh yeah we hear it
all
almost every day every comment like
every show right it doesn't affect me
well before we get into that i'm going
to have
candy read from first john 2 15 through
17. this is going to kind of be our
our scripture theme as we go through
several presentations this being the
first
yeah first john chapter 2 verses 15
through
love not the world neither the things
that are in the world
if any man love the world the love of
the father is not
in him for all that is in the world the
lust of the flesh
the lust of the eyes and the pride of
life is not of the father but is of the
world and the world's passeth away and
the lust thereof
but he that doeth the will of god
abideth forever
well there's a lot in there um
we're told you know in another place in
scripture that we are to be
in the world but not of the world
right which is kind of what it's
alluding to here but we're not supposed
to love
this world what do you think that is why
or what does that mean yeah why why do
you think we're not supposed to love
this world
because the the world at large
is following after their own desires
which lead to destruction
ultimately most of the time i mean we
like
doing drugs and fornicating all these
things that
you know just cause harm to you or your
fellow man around you
and there's a song like we're just
pilgrims passing through and if the
program like gets distracted they never
reach their destination
yeah so that's where my mind was going
it's like we're not even gonna be here
much longer
right don't get too attached to this
place right yeah
you look like you were going to say
something no i was just going to say
like you know i i see that
god has a totally different idea of of
what is pleasurable what is good in the
world as as opposed to what we see in
the world it's sort of
an opposite opposite ends of the
spectrum
yeah that's a good thought well
i guess i'm going to start out with this
premise that whatever you watch
read or listening or you're listening to
that's shaping who you are
and what you want to become okay not me
not you yeah which means you really
should be asking yourself
what do i want to become right i think
people don't realize
like you listen to certain types of
music because you identify with those
musicians
you watch certain types of movies
because you like to identify with those
certain types of movies
if you like superheroes you want to put
yourself in those superhero movies
maybe there's something in your life
that you wish you could be that or
whatever so
um i think it speaks more about who we
are than
i think what people realize i remember
seeing a psychology today
post that said um if you just sat down
with somebody and they named their top
10 movies you could actually
psychologically profile them
yeah i've seen that before so you know
it speaks volumes
and you know what kind of art you're
into
yeah and imagine if that was like
controlled or something like
tv only showed this particular type of
movie would that shape a culture would
it shape the mentality
because when you mentioned uh it doesn't
affect me and then you mentioned uh
what you're listening to watching i was
thinking of different cultures in the
world like
to say it doesn't affect me is kind of
really ignorant you know when you
look around and see like entire nations
are a certain way they have this culture
their music sounds different a certain
way you know and the things they watch
are a certain way
so i remember watching um something with
my daughter
it was just like a bunch of different
clips of people doing something nice for
homeless people and it like it brought
me to tears it was emotional it was nice
it
made me feel good i was like imagine if
television only showed this
what would the world be like i mean
every time i catch a glimpse of
mainstream television someone's always
being killed
someone's always hooking up you know
it's always
like literally it's almost always
something not good so do you do girls
know who madonna is
yes
she's still out there but um i remember
when i was a kid madonna would actually
go
into certain countries and they would uh
literally tell her if she did certain
things on stage they would arrest her
and you think that's just entertainment
right you're just watching
why would they care whatever she does
i mean what kind of an influence that
would have on the people and you know
certain countries that won't allow
movies to be played in there
you know it's been hong kong banned
certain movies
why because they didn't want that to
entice people to protest more than they
already were
all right put you guys on the spot a
little bit you don't have to answer this
if you don't want to do you only listen
to christian music
no i do not i barely listen to music
yeah unless you would count instrumental
stuff to be
non-christian yeah like aside from like
classical or whatever you know like like
that
um every once in a while put on like uh
you know i don't know michael buble um
for some reason to be honest i was we're
setting up the set and i was thinking
close your eyes
i don't know why i don't know where it
came from but it's in there somewhere
yeah there was a time in my life i i
don't
i choose not to listen to secular music
i would say
probably 99 of the time now i just don't
find that it's edifying for me so i've
just
i used to listen to all kinds of stuff i
was more of the alternative rock kind of
guy now that might surprise the viewers
out there and see me that way but um you
know it was like
i had friends that were into like nine
inch nails and insane clown posse and
metallica that wasn't my bag
but you know three doors down nickelback
wall flowers masterbox 20. you know that
was
that was my music of choice
you guys have probably had this
experience before you might listen to a
song
the first time you're like you know it's
okay
after you listen to it a few more times
you're like you know i kind of like that
song
and then after a few more repetitions
you're like this is the best song ever
it's like my favorite song and you're
playing it over and over
you don't often think about um how it is
you're being molded
uh by the things you're exposed to
around you
and so i just you know i think a lot of
people can identify with that
um liking increases with familiarity
has that happened to you guys before you
like you listen to a song and then it's
like over time
i remember buying albums way back when
that was a thing you know
you go to the cd store and you'd buy a
cd and
whatever my favorite band was and then
bringing it home and it was just like
brand new never heard it before wasn't
even on the radio
and then it was just kind of strange
like you know the first time you hear it
you'd be like yeah this is this is kind
of weird
yeah and then all of a sudden you'd
listen to it more and more and more and
i i think
and i don't know if you're going to
touch on this but there's familiarity in
our brains
that actually anticipate the sounds that
are going to come
and your your mind releases more
pleasure seeking
chemicals i wasn't quite going to go
there but i was going to talk about this
have you heard of the mere
exposure effect this is a psychological
term it's a phenomenon by which people
tend to develop a preference for things
merely because they are more familiar
with them
okay so in other words the more you see
something the more you're familiar with
it
the more you're familiar you are with it
the more comfortable you are with it
right and you've probably
you can probably identify with that in
in some way shape or form
isn't that the tactic parents use with
their kids about certain foods
yeah just keep my kids don't escape
you know they're gonna get it over and
over again and probably light until they
like it
um you guys probably know this by
intuition though right you think about
it
if you wanted to befriend like an animal
especially if it's like a wild animal
you know you first just kind of like
show up let them see you
and you keep moving a little bit closer
each day
soon you'll be next to them they can
smell you you know after a few times
they might take food from you
and they're just kind of warming up to
you overall
and uh i just try to snatch them that's
what it is i just throw a towel over it
down to the barn the other day and he
was like i was caught a rabbit
oh my goodness i did i wanted this
little bunny he was so
cute so i was just like looked around
for something to like grab him with and
he was too quick so that's a mere
exposure effect
and we see this principle at work in
different things you see it in wall
street actually traders will typically
trade domestic stocks
because they're more familiar with them
even though international stocks
may be a better investment okay you also
see this
uh with the advertising industry right
brands are constantly trying to put
something in front of your eyes
because they know the more you see it
the more familiar
you are with it the more comfortable you
are with it right
and so the reason that helps them
is because brands are trying to
communicate a message
right it can be a subtle message we've
talked about this before whether it's
whether you want to call it subliminal
or whether you want to just call it very
clever graphic design
it's communicating something to you so
i'm going to show you guys a couple
things that i picked up some of these
you've seen before
this first one may be new have you ever
seen
this pittsburgh zoo and aquarium logo
that looks really cool what do you see a
tree
yeah what else do you see two faces of
like a monkey and a lion or something
do you also notice there's fish in the
bottom that looks like water
oh yeah and then there's the birds at
the top too that are like
part of the tree or something it's
really clever you know you see that and
it's communicating oh you know this tree
is very natural but then there's also
the animals there too you know
it's really communicating um about the
zoo and what
they're all about i've seen some others
i think it was the brooklyn zoo
where it had um you know some giraffes
and under the giraffes the legs were in
the shape
of the distinct buildings of new york
city
this is very clever right whether or not
you like chocolate you've probably heard
of this
hershey's kisses right have you ever
seen the kiss
in the logo yeah i've never noticed that
yeah it's there right
they're trying to communicate something
about their brand there
trying to get you to see that product
over and over again
i talk about this one whenever i go and
present often tostitos
yeah this one's pretty cool if you've
never seen this before i'm about to ruin
it for you
here it is it's in the middle two people
eating chips and salsa and what do they
sell
they sell chips and they sell salsa so
when you pick up the one
it's a subtle message that you also go
and get the other great marketing
yeah great idea right amazon whatever
you think of amazon what do you think of
smile it has everything exactly it has
everything right everything from a to z
oh wow all right now i've always seen
the smile but never paid attention to
the a to z yeah they're connecting that
for you a to z
and it's a subtle thing you're not
necessarily consciously picking up but
it is communicating something about
their brand and i say that all the time
and i get amazon i can get everything on
amazon
right another one fedex
you guys have for fedex and if you've
never seen this before i want to warn
you
you will never be able to unsee this
okay
there it is it is the arrow
yeah boom so sorry to ruin that for you
but you definitely can't unsee it
you can't unsee it yeah what about
apple and ibm you guys may have heard us
talk about this before but if you
haven't
there was a brand exposure study that
was done by duke university a number of
years ago
and they basically wanted to see what
happens if you expose people to a brand
subliminally does it change how you
think about
anything and so they did that they took
the two brands ibm
apple subliminally primed people did the
two logos and
distracted them by adding numbers on the
screen in front of them
and then they took those two groups you
know they were they were separated and
they said okay now create
come up with as many creative uses for a
brick as you possibly can
brick's pretty mundane object so you're
thinking the list is probably going to
be short
and they found that people who were
subliminally primed to the apple logo
were all had a lot more creative uses
for a brick than people who were
primed for the ibm logo which was
interesting
it's more interesting in light of their
slogans so
ibm has a slogan that says think
okay apple's slogan is think
different right and i wonder
if apple is giving a subtle nod to ibm
right because they're both kind of in
the same business right
technology and so um generally people
that buy apple products are your
creatives you know you're videographers
photographers
graphic designers and they're those
people that say yeah i want to think
different i want to be creative
and so you can see their brand you know
has an effect on people
it's almost like they're like yeah you
could think with ibm but think different
come to us yeah a little slam on them
yeah a little bit a little bit so as
you're exposed to all these brands and
products they're coupled with
different appeals right and
in some way shape or form all these
appeals are really
tugging at your emotions so whether it
be the
adventure appeal or the statistics
appeal you know like uh
you know four out of five dentists
recommend colgate that's where keith
gets his
selling points from yeah yeah there's
the problem
problem in solution you know you have
acne here's clarisol or whatever it is
there's music scarcity fear humor
romance there's
all these different things you know the
endorsement the testimonial
they're tugging at your emotions they're
trying to appeal to you in some way
shape or form
to buy into their product buy into the
ideas
that they're putting forth um
i don't know if i've said this on the
show or not i know i've said it
out in front of people speaking
i used to buy axe soap i don't anymore
the reason i don't buy axe soap anymore
is because on the back of the bottle
are very not so subtle messages and i
have three boys
one of which is now 13 almost 14 in
about
two more weeks and i don't want them
seeing
the messages that are not so subtle on
the back of the bottles
so if you've ever used xsoap in your guy
you know what i'm talking about
and that's why i use you know doug men
now you know
the squatch so commercials that always
come on every time i'm on youtube
those things are raunchy yeah so anyway
they're
they're communicating something about
their brand to you that you can
identify with and it's appealing to your
emotions in some way shape or form
always like try to tell people that what
they're trying to do is create what's
called the positive emotional
attachment and emotion is such a
powerful motivator when it comes to
getting you to do
just about anything but we're not just
emotions are we
nope we are a biochemical machine
and uh these emotions happen when we
release a variety of
chemicals in our bodies because that's
how god made us
you know it just made us to respond to
things in different ways
and they're very natural responses one
thing i think is interesting is if you
look at addiction science
much of the brain is that is affected
um when it comes to this kind of thing
is
the part of the brain that controls our
emotions
okay so you're you're watching something
and your
your part of your brain is being
affected is the emotional part of your
brain
so they they kind of know they've
figured out you know over time
all these brands have spent not just
money on advertising but money on
science
to figure out how do we get your brain
to
do what we want it to you know to
heighten that emotional
sense and so your brain releases
happy chemicals these are the happy
chemicals
dopamine oxytocin serotonin
and endorphins okay now
the advertising industry is not the only
ones that know
how to get these things to do their
thing
right there's another industry one that
we talk about all the time
hollywood right they also know how to
get that chemical response out of you
and so when you're being exposed to
entertainment you can expect
that your emotions will release these
different chemicals
okay i mean it's probably why people
really like like horror movies right
yeah because you're getting scared i
don't like i don't know
adrenaline's not not on here yeah but
what would the
what would be associated with it uh i
don't know which one's associated with
adrenaline was that one
endorphins endorphins um i don't know
endorphins are released by the limbic
system
and so um they're really powerful
like way more powerful than morphine
which is interesting when you think
about it
but we're basically um it kind of boils
down to this when you see something
you listen to something it gives you a
reward
with a happy chemical usually dopamine
that's that's the one
we talk about a lot it's that that good
feeling that rewards your brain you're
like
yeah you know that feels good but
your brain also thinks how can i get
more i like that i want that
how do i get more of that so you do it
again and again
and again and it's not always bad you're
actually designed this way
to be able to form healthy habits
but it can create unhealthy habits for
example
you eat something it tastes good it
reinforces that you should keep feeding
yourself
to a point right i mean you need to get
full and not overeat
but it reinforces the idea that you
should keep eating
to live right it's a good thing i think
we're just like in an over
stimulated environment that we were
never really supposed to be in
but the flashing movies and all that as
opposed to just being at the park and
seeing your kids laugh
you probably get the same endorphins or
whatever but then you
you keep feeding it with these movies or
like instead of
fruit or something you're like candy or
whatever these real intense
um condensed versions or whatever right
yeah like concentrations our body were
never really designed to handle
and this is why people actually have
addictions so
what kind of addictions do we have well
dopamine is actually released when you
have sex
when you eat food or when you gamble all
those things
right and and some of those things not
everything not all three of those things
are
good but it's the same the chemical
that's released when you're operating
your cell phone you're on social media
right all what i think is interesting is
all three of these components are used
to
make this attractive yeah
what is las vegas known for cincinnati
city right
they got the food they got the gambling
they got
yeah they got the prostitution whatever
your pleasure whatever your pleasure
is right this is vegas stays in vegas
dopamine
releasing capital right over
releasing capital so i want to show you
guys some videos about
addiction science and we're going to
walk through these and talk about them
and it's kind of leading up to something
that i think is
interesting i don't think it's 100 right
but i think it's interesting
so i think you guys will too what causes
say
heroin addiction this is a really stupid
question right
it's obvious we all know it heroin
causes heroin addiction
here's how it works if you use heroin
for 20 days
by day 21 your body would physically
crave the drug ferociously
because there are chemical hooks in the
drug that's what addiction means
but there's a catch almost everything we
think we know about addiction
is wrong what a way to start almost
everything we know about addiction is
wrong
i think i remember reading one one one
place that dopamine is actually
instrumental in the anticipation of
and so it's like the building up to it
because
when you actually eat food your body is
releasing dopamine
but it's if you look at the graph it
shortly goes down right after you start
taking food
so it's like driving you to do it and
then once you do it it's like
tapering it off yeah i know a recovered
meth head that would be like you know
they they went through all the
um rehabilitation and everything but
afterwards we were just having a
conversation they were like yeah i used
to love
everything about it you know opening the
foil and breaking it down and
like oh i need to stop romanticizing
about it they were like that's what they
were told in rehab did not romanticize
so it's like the whole process
i think that's the way it is with
smoking and stuff too a lot of people
when they stop smoking they just miss
that action of
every time after i eat i do this or
every time after i use the bathroom i do
this thing or whatever
and the body likes routine right and
doesn't it take about 20 days to form a
habit or a routine
so it's like you have the addiction and
the like your body likes this regularity
and it just like all these things piled
in
yeah so i don't again i don't
necessarily know that i agree with their
premise that everything we know about
addiction science is wrong
but they're leading up to something and
which i think is interesting so
we'll talk about it here's the next
section if you for example
break your hip you'll be taken to a
hospital and you'll be given loads of
diamorphine for weeks or even months
diamorphine is heroin it's in fact much
stronger heroin than any addict can get
on the street
because it's not contaminated by all the
stuff drug dealers dilute it with
there are people near you being given
loads of deluxe heroin in hospitals
right now
so at least some of them should become
addicts but this has been closely
studied
it doesn't happen your grandmother
wasn't turned into a junkie by her hip
replacement
why is that our current theory of
addiction comes in part from a series of
experiments
that were carried out earlier in the
20th century the experiment is simple
you take a rat and put it in a cage with
two water bottles
one is just water the other is water
laced with heroin or cocaine
almost every time you run this
experiment the rat will become obsessed
with the drugged water
and keep coming back for more and more
until it kills itself
you guys familiar with that experiment i
am i'm interested
though that they said that the patients
don't become addicts
usually i've heard stories where they do
but i'm i'm sure that
i'm interested it is interesting yeah
have you guys ever heard of rat park
oh yeah yes they stadium i did hear
about this yeah
i'm okay cool what do you know about rav
park
we talked about a little bit on uh the
social media one but it's like
it's basically your environment is what
causes you to become an addict
if you're in this depressing environment
then you're just going to keep go to
that drug or whatever but
if there's a better option if there's
like fun things around you then
you're less likely to become an addict
and nailed it yeah
all right well we'll watch through these
videos but that's yeah that's basically
the premise behind rat park
but in the 1970s bruce alexander a
professor of psychology
noticed something odd about this
experiment the rat is put in the cage
all alone it has nothing to do but take
the drugs
what would happen he wondered if we
tried this differently
so he built rat park which is basically
heaven for rats
it's a lush cage where the rats would
have colored balls tunnels to scamper
down
plenty of friends to play with and they
could have loads of sex
everything a rat about town could want
and they would have the drugged water
and the normal water bottles but here's
the fascinating thing
in rat park rats hardly ever use the
drugged water
none of them ever use it compulsively
none of them ever overdose
but maybe this is a quirk of rats right
well
helpfully there was a human experiment
along the same lines
the vietnam war twenty percent of
american troops in vietnam were using a
lot of heroin
people back home were really panicked
because they thought there would be
hundreds of thousands of junkies on the
streets of the united states when the
war was over
i love their animations yeah they have
pretty good animations
so that's really interesting um
so when they came home from the war they
ceased
being heroin addicts basically yeah
there's there's actually a high
percentage of them and we'll see this in
the video
that didn't become addicts interesting
they were just happy to be home probably
yeah and and yeah it makes you wonder
there's probably several variables yeah
they're probably happy to be home
it makes you wonder like was it as easy
to get i don't know it probably depends
on where
you went back home like you know if your
inner city maybe it's easier if you're
out in the country maybe it's like
there's no dealers around anywhere right
for miles around
um so i don't know um but it's an
interesting point
again you know we're leading up to
something and i don't think they're 100
right but
it's an interesting study it's not the
chemicals
it's your cage we need to think about
addiction differently
human beings have an innate need to bond
and connect
when we are happy and healthy we will
bond with the people around us
but when we can't because we're
traumatized isolated or beaten down by
life
we will bomb with something that gives
us some sense of relief
it might be endlessly checking a
smartphone it might be pornography
video games reddit gambling or
it might be cocaine but we will bond
with something
because that is our human nature the
path out of unhealthy bonds
is to form healthy bonds to be connected
to people you want to be present with
addiction is just one symptom of the
crisis of disconnection that's happening
all around us
we all feel it since the 1950s the
average number of close friends an
american has
has been steadily declining at the same
time the amount of floor space in their
homes
has been steadily increasing to choose
floor space over friends
to choose stuff over connection the war
on drugs we've been fighting for almost
a century now
has made everything worse instead of
helping people heal and getting their
life together
we have cast them out from society we
have made it harder for them to get jobs
and become stable we take benefits and
support away from them if we catch them
with drugs
we throw them in prison cells which are
literally cages
we put people who are not well in a
situation that makes them feel worse
and hate them for not recovering oh wow
it's interesting when you put in that
perspective yeah it is it is yeah it's
very interesting when you put it in that
perspective
and you do see that i know people
personally they're just like
they go to jail and they you know they
come out and you think you're
they're better off but yeah they can't
get a job and they don't have a car and
all this stuff and they're just right
back into
drugs back in jail it's not like a real
rehabilitation
system that's basically trying to put
somebody into society and make them
better yeah
i don't know if you're going to get into
this about a different way to
handle prisoners no not going there okay
i have heard of other countries that
instead of keeping them locked up and
stuff they have them
gardening and doing all these cool
things and they come out a lot better
even murders and everything they just
come out like great people
yeah i have heard about that in other
other countries like northern european
countries it's like
you know instead of walking about they
sent them out in the woods with a
chainsaw and say this is your job cut
down some trees
yeah you know i actually heard about the
the vietnam war study so
i i don't know who actually did the
study but they came to conclusion that
because they have better options they
can overcome their addiction
they when they say they had those
addiction because they had nothing
better to do
when they were at war
[Music]
yeah and you think about all the
emotions that go with that i mean
you're like probably tense all the time
like
you gotta be on that on guard on watch
you don't know if somebody's gonna like
kill you at any moment you need
something to take the edge off yeah
so anyway but where i think they're
hitting uh
on this is the relationship part of it
you know we are seeing a lot of broken
relationships in it
and then getting involved in addictions
like our phones or
you know social media or whatever is
just is just
creating a much bigger divide even so
it's like this
you know terrible cycle that's that's
driving us further and further apart
and now everybody's social distancing
and it's just kind of like adding to the
fuel to the fire yeah sure that doesn't
help
for too long we've talked only about
individual recovery from addiction
but we need now to talk about social
recovery because something has gone
wrong with us as a group
we have to build a society that looks a
lot more like rap park
and a lot less like those isolated cages
we are going to have to change the
unnatural way we live
and rediscover each other the opposite
of addiction
is not sobriety the opposite of
addiction
is connection
interesting for sure yeah so interesting
point i really like the
relational points i don't think it's the
you know they're
they're trying to pit is it physical
substance abuse or the environmental
factor that's most important
uh likely i think both are true
um it's it's actually hard to duplicate
or replicate
substantiate some of alexander's ideas
about
um the environmental um social aspect
but there is some
uh truth to it i think there's some
truth to it
i would say also spiritually speaking
there's a lot of truth to that
yeah in a sense if we surround ourselves
um you know with people we don't really
feel a connection to
uh or we're not making meaningful
relationships
um you know it's real easy to gravitate
to
you know addictive type things rather
than if you have a good church family or
you you know you're you're bonding well
with your friends and family
spiritually it can make a big difference
as well no i totally agree and
and i should probably say it now because
i don't remember if i put it in later
but
i think that healing relationship with
christ
is really the answer to addiction kind
of like they were alluding to
it's it's not it's not you know it's
connection
that's the important the important thing
so and even if you don't have a lot of
friends in real life
you know you need to have a close
connection with christ and he gives you
the power to overcome anything
and that's the consistency all humans
need i mean it's great to have human
relationships but we make mistakes and
the pain can easily come back
but christ is the one that has that
consistent love that reliability
so you guys are heard in the garden of
eden right yeah
do you know what the word eden means
paradise doesn't it
actually means pleasure so
it's really the garden of pleasure
as human beings we were designed to
experience
pleasure god made us that way so there's
nothing wrong with experiencing pleasure
but what satan has done is he has
used pleasure to exploit us
right forms of pleasure that we were not
meant to
so you mean pleasure can be a good thing
i mean yeah
it could be ironic actually
so we go to genesis 3 6 it says so when
the woman saw the tree was good for food
when eve picked that fruit it was
appealing to her
natural flesh to her desires right
there was nothing wrong with the food
itself
right god just like advertising
he causes an association right and he
says
um eating the tree or the fruit of the
tree equals death
okay that's the association when god
said don't do it then the action
of her picking the fruit that's what
becomes sin
and the wages of sin has always been the
same thing paul says
the wages of sin is death that was the
consequence
for what she did what adam did with
human race did
it's always been death from the
beginning and so there's this war going
on between
good and evil and the war is really for
each one of our hearts
right who will you give your heart
to right eve her
god had her heart prior to that moment
right but then she gave her heart to
somebody else
yeah so who are you going to give your
heart to
we are being moved away from devotion
that's true okay and we're being moved
to desire right
we're being moved away from what god
wants to what we want
and uh that's actually a philosophy of
the world
and we call that hedonism you know it
has various forms
uh the point is pleasure is what is good
pain is what is bad
and so you're trying to maximize one and
minimize the other
that's hedonism you gotta be careful
looking that word up on the internet by
the way
there's kind of a post-modernist view of
that too if it feels good do it yeah i
mean like
you see that in in in the modern setting
as well
yeah so
here's what the bible says the bible
says put on the lord jesus christ
and make no provision for the flesh
to fulfill its lusts
now that doesn't mean it's easy
right that's why you need jesus right
that's why we have to put on jesus
because it's not easy but that we have
to make
no provision for the flesh christ made
us
he made us for pleasure he he made us
for things that we can enjoy
but he knows how to give lasting
pleasure these other things that we're
grasping at they're limited pleasure
right they're the temporal pleasures of
the world
that's weird because it's like they're
they're both easy and hard for different
reasons like
it's easier it's like it's easier just
to go into a store and buy a bottle of
beer
but is it really easier to do that than
to
pray before you even go in or open your
bible or just not go in
yeah but it's like it's like to your
flesh it is
sometimes it's hard just to read the
bible or make yourself pray
but it's only hard to your flesh because
when you think about it which is easier
opening up a bible reading something or
going in and making a purchase popping
it open you know
yeah so but but i kind of think it's
always
similar to the food topic you know if
you eat healthy food you
know you're gonna feel good right you
know that like when you walk away from
that meal or whatever you know you you
just feel great
um when you eat something that's just
full of of
you know things that you shouldn't eat
tons of fat tons of oil tons of butter
tons of whatever right
you feel like ah that that hurts
yeah i shouldn't have done that but it
was sure good tasting
while it was going in your mouth so
you're pleasing that one little part of
your body so the rest of your body has
to suffer
and it's kind of like flipping that
mindset and and
learning how to appreciate the you know
the simple things in life
another thing it's like set like a verse
that says like set your mind on eternal
things
that's what we need to be looking at the
big bigger picture not the temporary fix
that's
not it's just going to go away and
you're just going to go back for it and
it's
going to damage your life i like this
promise in the bible it says from psalm
16 11 it says
you will show me the path of life and
your presence
is fullness of joy at your right hand
are pleasures
ever more amen so god is is not
you know a kill joy yeah right it says
in his presence is fullness
of joy and he's not there to like
ruin your entire pleasure experience on
this planet
he's there to make sure that you have
pleasure
forevermore amen and the bible also says
that
no ear has heard or i have seen the
things that are in store that
god has for us and him being the very
inventor of
pleasure um you know i think we could
only imagine
since we've kind of crawled through the
muck and mirey clay down here
it just seems fitting that god would
have something that is 10 times
better than what even initially planned
for us
um as just kind of a you know like like
a way of
of of saying wow you guys went through
that now let me show you something
that's just
will blow your mind imagine eating the
fruit of an unfallen tree
how much difference that's going to be
you know if you really think about it
most of the things that the advertising
industry or hollywood
does is they create an emptiness
in you so that they can fill it
yeah right they're creating some kind of
dissatisfaction
but you know every desire that they
promise to fulfill
can be found in christ that's right and
sometimes that emptiness is an illusion
which is more scary
you know you know i think eve
experienced the same thing
in the garden the things that she had um
was promised
if you think about it the original she
already had them yeah
right so it was the creation of an
emptiness
that didn't really exist you'll be like
god well i was created in the image of
god
right you were like god already
galatians 5 24 says this and those who
are christ
have crucified the flesh with its
passions
and desires again
that's not easy right it's tough
but if we're going to be with jesus
jesus says you know what you need to be
crucified
crucify that flesh with its passions its
desires its lusts
all of that and you know kill that
old man that wants things that are not
of my kingdom
i think like in any addiction the first
step
is you have to admit there's a problem i
mean you go to any sort of recovery
program that's they're going to tell you
you have to come to the place where you
say listen
i'm in a bad place and i need help
and that waving that little surrender
flag is the first thing that basically
god says now i can
start to work with you and help you
overcome and heal these so
i think with anything we get ourselves
into it's just that
that coming to god and just saying god i
need you i need a savior
i am i'm struggling with this and that
admitting of that
is the first step i think that god can
really begin to work with us and he's
very honest the verse doesn't say you
know put away or set aside it says
crucified that's right and crucifixion
ain't easy
but the promise is that he will be with
you every step of the way
yep other verse i wanted to bring out
for
everyone is that it's from first peter 4
2 it says
that he no longer should live the rest
of his time in the flesh for the lusts
of men but for the will of god
and we notice here uh the will of god is
directly contrasted
to serving ourselves and our desires
right in other words it's not it's not
both
right so we need to
serve the will of god that's what he's
called us to do but in calling us to
serve his will
like it said in the psalms you know
there's
in my presence there's fullness of joys
at my right hand there's pleasures
forevermore
so you're not losing anything right you
might
feel that way you might think that way
but you're not losing
anything galatians 5 16 says i say then
walk in the spirit and you shall not
fulfill
the lust of the flesh what i think is
really fascinating is if you look at the
broader context and i'll just look it up
here
in galatians you know what does that
mean
to fulfill the lust of the flesh what's
what's being included in that
and so here we have you start in verse
13 it says
for brethren ye have been called unto
liberty what's that
freedom freedom okay you're called to
freedom as a christian
you are free yeah okay so
use only use not liberty for an occasion
to serve what
the flesh wow so you're free
but he says don't use it to serve
yourself
to serve your flesh your own passions
your own desires
but by love serve one another
okay and so it goes on you know the
bigger picture i think it's really
important that we paint this bigger
picture says for all the law is
fulfilled
in one word even this you shall love
your neighbor as yourself
but if you bite and devour one another
take heed that you be not consumed
one of another this i say then walk in
the
spirit okay so we have a huge contrast
now we have the lust of the flesh
and we have walking in the spirit okay
they're opposite
you can tell by reading they are not the
same thing okay
let's go on it says and ye shall not
fulfill the lust of the flesh so he's
really hammering this point as paul is
like if you're walking in the spirit
you're not going to be fulfilling the
law the lust of the flesh
for the flesh lusts against the spirit
and the fear spirit against the flesh i
mean
how many times do we have to hammer this
like they are not the same thing
okay and these are contrary one to the
other
so that you cannot do the things that
you would but
if you be led of the spirit
you are not under the law okay well why
is that
well you have liberty right okay
so he says now the works of the flesh
are manifest
which are these okay now we're now we're
going to see what is it like
to express the lust of the flesh
right that we're not supposed to that
we're not supposed to do
listen to this adultery fornication
uncleanness lasciviousness idolatry
witchcraft hatred variants emulations
wrath
strife seditions heresies indians
murders drunkenness revelations
and such like of the which i tell you
before as i have
told you in time past that they which do
such things
shall not inherit the kingdom of god
so fulfilling that lust of the flesh
is opposite to the spirit and fulfilling
the lust of the flesh
you are as a christian you are free but
it says you shouldn't use your freedom
to do these things and they're in a
direct
contrast the way i read this list
so many of these things are against the
law of god yeah will not inherit the
kingdom of god
so yeah as a christian you are free
right but do you use that freedom to
abuse
god's law no
and to wrap it up he talks about what
the fruit of the spirit
is and um
and then you know he ends it in verse 26
it says let us not be desirous of vain
glory provoking one another envying one
another
so you know we go back to that question
we asked in the beginning is what do you
want to become
if you want to become like god
then you're not going to be doing these
things right right if you want to become
like the world then that's what you're
going to be doing
so if we have a flesh problem
essentially what we have is a heart
problem
yeah and so then our work is to submit
to heart
surgery right like this verse in psalm
139 23 and 24 it says
search me o god and know my heart
try me and know my anxieties and see if
there is any wicked way in me
and lead me in the way everlasting amen
so it's a beautiful verse rat park
sounds a lot like what heaven
was supposed to be right i mean not
exactly the same thing because we were
talking about
rats but uh for human beings if you
think about it
uh there's some implications that scotty
was alluding to earlier from the
christian perspective
people have feel they have real physical
addictions
we cannot deny that you know despite
what alexander's study said you know
whether it's
it's just a social construct or whatever
people have real physical addictions i
believe that yeah
but the solution to their addiction i
believe is relational
and it's found in that relationship with
christ there are so many people who have
overcome by coming to jesus yeah amen
because
nothing else would work and that is
the power of the gospel that's right
amen
so you know have you ever struggled with
an addiction that's
a really personal question perhaps maybe
you're on the other side of that and
that's great
do you currently struggle with an
addiction
if you're brave enough let us know in
the comments below
and you know let us know if what has
helped you the most if anything
let us know um you know we'd love to
pray for you
if you're struggling right now with some
kind of addiction and you're
going to put that in the comments below
we want to bring that to the lord in
prayer so that he can deliver you and
you will experience
that healing in the relationship that
jesus has provided so you guys have any
closing thoughts
philippians 4 13 i can do all things
through christ who strengthens me
amen amen all right well this has been
another episode of led
live and we thank you guys for watching
we thank you for joining us
there might be a poster to this one
candy and i were talking about it so be
on the lookout for that
and um you know if you're struggling
with anything
uh take it to god and he will
you know he makes promises in his word
that he will never leave you
nor forsake you and you can trust him
with your life remember it's in him
that is fullness of joy and pleasures at
his right hand
we'll see you guys next time take care
[Music]
foreign